hello everyone David and Karen a film
courage here today we will be chatting
with Jeremy Walker of Jeremy Walker &
Associates whose work includes the Blair
Witch Project Juno thank you for smoking
the house of the devil by ty West
paranormal activity and much more
welcome Jeremy thank you for joining us
yes hey thanks for having me you guys
yeah we're credibly honor to spend some
time with you here Jeremy and to start
off for those watching or listening and
and they may or may not be familiar with
what it is that you do can you sort of
just capsulize what it is that you do
well I'm a publicist but that has so
many different definitions and
transmutations and different
relationships to cinema right now I'm
earning a living or as best as anyone
can these days and running living as a
unit publicist on the set of movies as
they're made also consulting with people
as they bring their movies to film
festival you know I work out of my house
in Malibu which is neither sort of in a
very rural part of town I like to think
of myself as the Jim Rockford of
independent film publicity so I'm sort
of an independent guy I do my own thing
I do what I like to work but like to
work on so that sort of me in a nutshell
okay where does your appetite for
publicity come from and why film well
movie movies and specifically
independent film some sort of in the
water size but I sort of grew up in a
apprenticed in it was you know
sociologically I've told people it's
because movies were socially acceptable
to me and my peer group when I was a
teenager so you know also until people
and this is absolutely true that my dad
was a psychologist so I would wait for
him to finish his day in his waiting
room and it was the kind of
psychologists that had a stack of New
Yorker magazines as opposed to People
magazine's and they know it's true that
a lot of people trace their
love of cinema back to pawan kalyan in
my case it was practically true it was
hard for me to believe that someone
could make a living writing about cinema
and of course it was the only
interesting part of the new yorker which
every other section was boring if you're
a young person so it's sort of those two
things like socially acceptable and
where I grew up it's like if it someone
from GM you know grew up in Detroit I
grew up in Malibu and around at least
the periphery of that the industry being
right across the street so you know was
sort of inevitable in some way that
makes me wonder I mean it was a sort of
the challenge that drew you in you know
were you youth you find something you
discover something that you say you know
what I can't believe people make money
that way you know I want to go to make a
living that way what it was was there
was were you drawn to the challenge of
it you know i'll tell you the industry
literally came to me at a moment that
was very I it was at a point in my life
where I needed a mentor I needed that
person to say okay I'm about make this
movie I need your help i need someone
tell it might as well be you or you know
you dated my daughter in my case and you
wore a suit when you picked her up that
first date and so I automatically liked
you and it was really literally like
that and I was a production assistant in
the office and basically my job was to
drive all around Los Angeles and do
whatever I was told and it again it came
in at an absolutely right time but it
also a job like that instills in you um
you know sort of the prime directive of
movies first you shall do no harm second
you do everything you can to make that
movie protect that movie help anyone who
needs help on the crew help anyone who
needs help on the couch I mean it is
that sort of you know i like to call it
the prime director because that's what
it is you know
how do you sort of take that and sort of
branch that out it and begin your own
practice your own publicity practice I
have a number of mentors and they began
here in Hollywood the first guy to give
in to my job was a guy named Jim cats
and I didn't necessarily know this but
he began his career as a movie publicist
I mean he tells stories about movie
start he was at united artists and he
went and went on to run the classics
division at Universal so he re-released
a lot of the old Hitchcock movies back
in the 80s if you remember that so he
was sort of a part of the art don't
seeing here and here in town the way no
one else was anyway he wasn't my first
mentor my second mentor and publicity
was a woman in Carol white who truly was
you know I became her assistant then I
became a publicist in her New York
office she and I were literally I was in
her intern in college so I had great
mentors okay and and that's really what
anyone should seek out or or frame it is
you know it's like oh I need the job I
need the job well do you need a job or
do you need a mentor and from some of
the research we've done on you you've
said that it's not just enough to love a
movie in order to take it on you've got
to be able to love the movie and also
know that you can do something with it
how do you make this distinction it's a
very pragmatic way of looking at whether
or not someone like me or and I think
this also applies to any you know this
remember i'm in a service industry okay
agents managers publicists we're all
sort of in a service industry so you
know know what you want for your film I
think if you have an idea of a vision
for what you want you're looking for
someone who can help you bring that
vision to life at the same time you know
people like me the older we get the more
experience we have the more we know a
what's reasonable and possible and be
what's right for us and I passed on
plenty of movies that just weren't right
for me I knew intrinsically and they
went out to be huge hits sometimes it's
a pragmatic consideration you know I
read the script here's a good example
that spread and you know honest to god
the movie was little miss sunshine uh I
was having a sort of a hot streak jason
reitman had had me on the set of his
first movie I think and I think the same
producer was involved in both films a
very smart guy and he was like you know
I want to send you the script and I read
it right away I was troubled by it I
knew who was in it I thought it would be
a good movie I but I couldn't figure out
as a unit publicist okay as the person
responsible offense ostensibly for
bringing press on the set I couldn't
figure out how you bring press on to a
set that was for the entire movie except
for the end which you can't give away
how you bring press on the set which is
essentially an old Volkswagen bus that's
moving I couldn't figure out where you
put the unit still photographer in that
situation let alone anyone outside or
third-party as we like to say so I'm the
idiot that passed on little miss
sunshine I have more stories but you
probably have more questions so well in
speaking of still photographers I
believe you said that as still
photographer onset is all most important
or as important as a DP do you think
enough do you think filmmakers are
utilizing this the power of a still
photographer to take those set photos it
remains a struggle and it remains a
struggle i think for some very
old-school traditional reasons and uh
you know what's fascinating to me is
that and this is something i just
pragmatically learned and i don't know
why it took me my entire
you know career to figure this out but
you learn as you go um the still
photographer represents the
cinematographer when a cinematographer
when obscenity aquifer works with a
filmmaker works the director to create a
frame light in a particular way should
have particular way what gets
represented in every magazine every
newspaper is the still photographers
representation of that cinematographers
work so to somehow exclude or you know
shave days off in a production schedule
or not give full access to the stone
photographer is really hurting not just
I'm absolutely convinced it is the
future marketability of the film and
therefore the future intrinsic value of
the film especially in this digital age
when little bits of information are as
valuable they're like ammunition it's
like bullets or you know whatever for
for the machine you also have this issue
of representation if you don't give the
still photographer full access you don't
represent the costume designers
beautiful work you don't represent the
cinematographers before the gaffer's
work you don't represent a certainly the
actors the way that they could be
represented down the road so it really
is that important and I am that
passionate about it yes to answer your
question and at this point in your
career do you seek out projects or do
they come to you or a little of both a
little both I mean you know I look if
you know that there's one thing a
publicist can tell you it's that a big
part of the job is being rejected is
being ignored is being you know that's
it I don't I'm never going to hear from
that person again even though I shared
some really good ideas with them
and that could be as a journalist
pitching out where that could be as the
publicist pitching a journalist that
could be as a publicist or consultant
like me pitching a client you know I've
been known to send letters to heads of
networks suggesting certain talent go in
the anchor chair as those discussions
come on every so often so I'm not afraid
of pitching the big idea of the crazy
idea if you want to call it that at the
same time um I think very pragmatically
and when I'm on a movie set I think
particularly pragmatically and I usually
take a defensive posture you know what's
best for the movie do we expose it to
certain journalists do we not do we you
know just keep our heads down plow
through you know every movie is
different and every circumstance is
different so I hope that answers your
question you know you're going back to
the to the blair witch project because
that was a project that sort of came to
you you know what was it about that
project where you said you know what i
really want to take this this on and at
the same time what was that a project
that you had sort of been waiting for
was don't did you know did you have any
sort of sense of what might happen with
that one moving forward um you know the
blair witch project and paranormal
activity are both as the producer
paranormal activity has pointed out both
of those projects both of those films
are sort of once-in-a-lifetime once in a
career once every 10 years sorts of
things it's interesting to me that the
cover date for the Time and Newsweek
covers that sort of happened on the same
date out of the cover name is August
sixteenth 1999 happens to be my birthday
which is crazy happy Madonna's birthday
these elves died the sixteenth of August
so there's this weird sort of but those
happened at a very specific time in the
culture you know a little snipe on the
Time magazine cover that had ed and down
on it internet stocks are they worth it
I mean it's a ver that
we have a very specific time in our
culture and and it was the filmmakers
themselves I is absolutely true my
mentor Cara white once said about
Richard Linklater the film eight the
independent filmmaker is often the best
marketer of their own work and that's
absolutely true it's true in the case of
Richard like Richard Linklater and
slacker it was true in the case of the
Blair Witch boys and they ABS you know
the famous website already existed so to
sort of answer your you know before
before artisan or anybody bought the
movie it was a little goofier but you
know in a they were I think the first
filmmakers to completely participate in
and drive the creative force of the web
in their own film they'd always thought
of it in that way artisan recognize the
opportunity and brilliantly brilliantly
brilliantly created some amazing
opportunities original stuff stunts they
did they did everything any fantastic
independent filmmaker independent
distributor of the day did for this film
and they did a fantastic job on it so
you know and when did you get involved
with the blair witch project was before
sundance and then also how long did you
stay the coming Chris showed me the
movie in opt I believe my memory serves
October it had been submitted to
Sundance I do not know if they had been
given any heads up or whatever but they
were like being good proactive
filmmakers someone had given them my
name they showed me the movie and
anthology film archives way downtown I
guess it's where they could get a room I
don't know they filled it with some
people it was a relatively full
screening I don't know if it was friends
and family or what I do know that
Heather Donahue was in the house the
star of the movie and
I was introduced to her I think just for
a moment before the film began Louie
starts I see a little red dot in the
corner and I realized that the audience
is being videotaped so I'm like all
right that's interesting during the film
like I'm thinking to myself if they can
maintain this verisimilitude whatever
you want to call it but they can
maintain this you know illusion of found
footage real footage uh this movie could
work that's basically how I I felt about
it it totally did I said as much the
filmmakers afterwards like old Heather
dog you that I thought she was gonna be
you know her performance was amazing and
I thought she would be a big star and it
was uh it was great and we just talked
from there and you know that's how I
became involved what oh you wanted to
know also how long I was involved yes I
was involved through the theatrical
release of the hell okay and in my next
audition was when the client was artisan
who distributed the movie hired me oh
not me they hired the agency I worked
for it was a bicoastal situation Harry
Clyne I think at that point was if not
my partner certainly my partner in crime
his office in LA dude the la campagne so
it was a fascinating we you know helped
the movie go on the market we stayed
involved with the film the filmmakers
through release and I've continued to
consult with those guys occasionally I
mean you know I've been on the sets of
some of their movies there you know
there's they remain filmmakers they
remain extraordinary gentlemen I might
say too and you know we talked about
when artisan picked up the film you know
we believe that when it was picked up it
was sort of estimated that it was going
to gross between seven and eight million
dollars that was going to be that the
answer will run
the opening weekend it hit at 30 million
dollars you know what when did you begin
to believe that this film was going to
sort of exceed the expectations you know
when were you able to sort of sense that
this film was really going to sort of
skyrocket well you know I I don't want
to position myself as someone who
understands box office or numbers or
things like that in fact if I have a
flaw it's probably great for me to
reveal this on the internet and from God
and everybody but if I thought I'm not
good with numbers I never have been I've
been the kind of publicist you know at
places like Sundance I've always been
very interested in the deal of side how
publicity and and sales sort of
intersect okay that's kind of what
always fascinated me from the first time
I ever went to Sundance until today uh
so but I'm not I don't ask me about box
office don't ask me about numbers cuz
it's meaningless the figures and
circumstances you cited feel inaccurate
to me um the movie opened at the
angelika film center first I believe on
just one screen let's put it this way i
believe it was part of the playbook to
inflate demand by keeping supply small
so it was important and strategically
part of the goal to have them every show
sellout hi highest per screen average
it's a blockbuster that's when you
started to make that's when you started
to create momentum have cheap in the
marketplace everybody wanting this to
vote this movie I'm not a distribution
expert either but I can tell you a piece
of narrative that came about true things
happened and they both involved a movie
called the Catherine zeta-jones and it
was a universal picture called The
Haunting
right does this ring a bell it's like a
big elaborate maybe Amblin produced
remake of The Haunted anyway that was 20
but around the same time as the blair
witch project but the Blair Witch
Project numbers were so big that our
theater owners were really paying
attention to it and so the head of
distribution and it's probably horrible
to name names I don't know a woman
Universal named Nikki Rocco whose
legendary head of distribution and by
sharing the story I by no means have any
disrespect for her I don't even know her
maybe maybe met her once upon back of
the day but she did this thing or
somehow it happened where they've said
to move that huge studio movie away from
the blair witch project and they said
they told like variety or whatever why
they were doing it and so suddenly
there's this narrative okay about how
this little teeny movie is suddenly
Hollywood's afraid of it and that
literally was what was on the cover of
Time magazine or maybe it was Newsweek I
can't remember why Hollywood is afraid
of this movie and that became the
narrative the other thing that happened
was that after the all the critics prank
critics primarily were had given Blair
Witch Project pretty darn good reviews
Janet Maslin compared it to a I wouldn't
call this a good review but she called
it she compared it to a log cabin built
out of soda cans it's just something you
have to see I mean that's not exactly a
quote you put on that but aside from her
reviews were great when that Catherine
zeta-jones haunting a huge studio movie
open and simply was not in any way shape
or form scary wasn't funny it was just
this whatever huge bloated meaningless
thing the critics went after it and said
go
see the blair witch project instead so
it how many things contributed to the
success of this movie great distribution
team everyone artisan careers were made
on as a result of this movie you know it
was a huge team the west coast coast
office of client and felt quite a wider
plan walk or whatever it is I can't
remember they did a huge amount cover of
LA Weekly I mean there was a huge print
campaign that this movie had that was
you know uh just starting to be de
rigueur for movies that popped at
Sundance in the summertime and that sort
of pattern still exists today what we're
also curious about Jeremy is sort of the
size of the publicity teams that work on
the independent features that you work
on and how do the size of those teams
how do they compare and contrast with
with the publicity teams of those that
were gone on the larger studio films
okay what I said I was like Jim Rockford
like I was the Jim Rockford of
independent fell double city like he was
a long gun I'm a lone gun I do not keep
a 38 in the cookie jar but that's not a
question um you know so I work without
staff I work on basically one or two
films at a time that's what I like it
right now but you know I can sort of
answer the question because uh when I
had a office in New York it was me and
45 really talented people who really
cared about this particular segment of
the market place the character of it I
think is what really attracted us also I
have to say after being here for a while
I'm a native of southern california and
i'm a native of malibu but I
professionally I came of age and
practiced for a couple of decades in New
York so I sort of have both perspectives
um you know there's a reverence for
journalists
that exists in New York that I don't
think can possibly exist here in LA for
a number of reasons especially when it
comes to what I like to call the
Hollywood industrial complex okay
entirely different set of ethics set of
rules out here than in New York um the
other thing is that in New York this
wasn't the only game in town you know
publishing newspapers magazines morning
shows David Letterman and Conan O'Brien
you know there was a certain i like to
say that people in Los Angeles in the
industry or afraid of New York because
they couldn't control it and I think
that still exists to this day uh does
that have we sort of gone off track is
that okay you know I'm still hoping to
hear so you know I hear that you've had
a you know you're working with about
four or five people or you have on your
publicity side what about the studio
features when they on bro you know when
they roll out of film how large scale
are their publicity teams you know I'm
not going to really answer that question
because I don't have a great huge vast
amount of experience hug inside how
Studios work a little bit for in there
ok I will say this well there's new york
there's Los Angeles everything in
between it's that everything in between
infrastructure that was as is as
responsible for the success of let's
just say the blair witch project and
paranormal activity both of those films
shared this that infrastructure has a
horrible umbrella of regional those are
often the real unsung heroes of
the craft of publicity at least in terms
of releasing movies maybe nationwide
creating this little phenomenon it can't
just be New York you can't just be Los
Angeles it has to be everywhere else too
for an actor or a filmmaker how
important is it for them to know their
own personal story before they go to the
press about their film sort of their
elevator pitch how important is that
that they kind of know their own little
quick background a little catchy
soundbite about who they are before they
go to the press about their film you
know not every every movies different
personal narrative created the brothers
McMullen personal narrative created Ed
Burns intern or PA or whatever
Entertainment Tonight in New York mother
did the catering his film worked on some
level of the right place right time
sundance film festival tom rathman Fox
the Fox Searchlight was created
basically by that movie in a lot of ways
that was all personal narrative so not
every film has one okay it's called back
story or used to be not every film has
one sometimes the backstory of quote
independent films unquote so lurid and
fraught with you know the usual uh
Horrors interpersonal [ __ ] after
making an independent film oh my god
we've all heard the stories you know how
does that become part of the film's
backstory what's the line where do you
cross it that's kind of where a
publicist a smart one can help a
filmmaker I've told people in the past
and I'm as much you know a marriage
counselor as I am a you know media
strategist sometimes when
to these companies so Mike this because
it's you know independent films are
intrinsically more personal there are
more issues and I think to answer your
question to some degree part of it is
helping the filmmaker articulate what's
their their film their vision for it but
also how it works in the context of what
else is going on in the whole world so
you know and it would cease did you get
involved with Paranormal Activity wasn't
the film dormant for a few years before
you became a part of the project the
producer Jason Blum showed the movie to
me at his house with a few other people
Oren Peli was there Bret Easton Ellis
was there which really really freaked me
out because I'm a huge fan and um
afterwards we talked about the movie I
recognized that it was intrinsically
commercially you know again you get that
feeling if they can pull it off then you
know sky's the limit and if then it was
press pause for a while and then um you
know I I think that's all I'm gonna say
because I could tell a really good story
about open event of a miracle or the LA
Film Festival and what came across
everybody's blackberries that night I've
never seen that happen before but it was
amazing after that happened it was like
full steam ahead and he and I were
talking and it was great so in that
night you're sitting amongst a crowd of
people watching this film what did you
see in it that gave it that sort of
where you got this aha moment did you
see the same elements that the blair
witch project had you know it's funny
the boot it's been mentioned that the to
have certain things in common they have
in common the first person narrative but
they have a very very different
aesthetic if you go back at the steven
soderbergh movie bubble okay
one of the first high-definition video
productions that went to Toronto Film
Festival it was it was a great great
steven soderbergh movie i thought the
one word he used to describe his
methodology or whatever you want to call
it stillness that movie was set in the
factory where people paint you know
assembled plastic dolls and they worked
very slowly and so the whole frame was
still paranormal activity it was also
about stillness it was also about
fast-forward it was also got pause it
was also about first person video
diaries so large project if you think
about it was all about motion it was all
about being woken up woken awakened in
the middle of the night and having the
[ __ ] scared out of you you knew it was
coming just as the actors did and that
was also about method filmmaking I
believe that the actors were in a great
deal of control quote unquote they
certainly had an editorial voice in the
creation of the film itself in the Blair
Witch Project I feel like Paranormal
Activity one thing that Oren Peli talks
about is how yes it is a camera on a
tripod absolutely still but it took him
months to figure out what that
absolutely still frames should be
something you don't think about when you
think about that movie necessarily I
just want to ask you about this the
Steven Spielberg story is attached to
paranormal activity the one where he I
don't know what I'm going to interrupt
you because I know I know about the
story that you're talking about but did
you make up the story is that a story I
made up or tell us the truth about that
seriously I feel like Bill Gates right
now it's not helpful it's not germinate
it's not relevant no I'm kidding look uh
the reason I don't want to talk about it
was because it came about I had nothing
to do
that was not my purview um here's what I
know it's if you look at the executives
involved who went from dreamworks to
paramount when they rub together for
however many you know when they
populated for a while who stayed where
those people were in they knew the dude
it's absolutely plausible you know
absolutely possible I mean of course you
would give steven spielberg a DVD of the
movie duh anyway what's I said I had
nothing to do that so I can move on past
had you know what one thing that would
be really helpful sir audience and
something that has not talked about
regarding Paranormal Activity really is
the fact that before this movie was
known before this movie blew up you know
they started in college towns around the
country and they sold out 12 out of 13
scrutiny Oh midnight screenings in
college towns what kind of effort what
kind of work did they put into those
screenings to sell out this this movie
you know I I think I covered that
because when I talked about the people
who work in the places that are not New
York and Los Angeles okay I think it was
a fascinating petry dish as in totally
outside observer I did not contribute to
that decision I wasn't part of that
decision but I thought it was
fascinating petry dish in which to as it
was a college town it was the right
audience um you know they can be
prepared for the movie in some way I'm
not saying that there was a you know a
lot of voodoo or anything I do know that
the studio was in touch with the
exhibitors very closely I do know that
they heard about the audience directly
from you know all that stuff and the
other thing that you have to remember is
that the other side of this I don't want
to give say say it was only the regional
people but they do deserve a huge
man of credit for this it was also like
I suppose the Blair Witch Project used
internet technology to enable the
audience to talk about the movie you
know the movie is intrinsically scary
let the audience share that with each
other and so literally I never seen this
done before a a me Powell who's the head
of interactive marketing and now the
head of insurgents / own division it a
paramount she and her fantastic staff
had laptop computers in the lobby so on
the way out that audience members were
divided to tweet their screen and
Thompson has already raved about this at
indiewire it's absolutely true it's
never been done before was absolutely
genius it was the right medium for the
right movie at the right moment and it
was really cool to see that happen but I
had nothing to do with it I can't take
credit for it her name is Amy Powell
she'd been rewarded with her own
division apparently and that was my next
question because it appears that
paranormal activity seem to pop so to
speak much easier than the blair witch
project and so is it ah is it a simple
fact of well the maturity of the
internet okay it's a great great great
question a lot of times and this is so
true if you're at all in the optimists
game that is independent film you've it
been in it for any amount of time you
know sometimes it takes time for great
movies to write them okay in the case of
paranormal activity it always was a
great movie always was a great movie it
took you know and and just as a
publicist can do a thousand different
things a producer can do a thousand
different things too and the producer of
this movie this character Jason Blum
also knew intrinsically that sometimes
movies need to write them he has his own
amazing resume but he recognized the
potential
film he stayed with it he knew when it
was time to let it ripen he was the
first person to bring the press in
strategically on this movie you know so
it did take a long time and that's sort
of why I think it's interesting you say
the Blair Witch Project you know both of
those movies popped paranormal activity
pops because the buildup of pressure
inside the bottle needed a lot of time
relatively speaking getting into a wine
metaphor I better watch it all turn into
Elvis Mitchell in purchasing food
metaphors match um no but that if that
needed time to write the blair witch
project was a relatively fast
acquisition you can say truly that that
would be popped at Sundance paranormal
activity i think was rejected by
sundance it's all has to do with timing
all has to do the right people
recognizing what the movie can do six
months a year from now in this
environment and it's always a crapshoot
too there's plenty of good movies that
should be getting taking advantage of
all these creative new creative deals
that are probably are but again it takes
time sometimes sometimes they do pop and
that's exciting you know so many so many
sort of people in our world so many
filmmakers you know we're at the sort of
this DIY age you know and you have
someone like John research writing a
book think outside the box office where
you know we're taking on the
responsibility of sort of not only
making the work but also working to push
it out there and sort of you know self
distribute you know along those lines
you know for those of us who are doing
that how many media outlets should
actors and directors target you know is
there is there a sort of no should
shouldn't we be more focused on going
after quality or focused ongoing effort
quantity okay that is a really
interesting question first of all you
know I like to say that in this era of
uh you know the internet and fornicate
you know terminators who become govern
aiders who are fornicators the idea of
choosing outlets has really acquaint it
depends on the news it depends on the
project depends on the film depends on
the circumstances if this is a movie
that's going to market is this movie
that's or going on the market is this a
movie that you're releasing two
gazillions of moviegoers is this a video
on demand I mean the there are too many
spheres that your question and compasses
to answer concisely that said you know
we're in the age that one media outlet
is all it takes to create a sensation
it's called a scoop it's the one thing
about journalism that hasn't changed in
this era The Terminator turned
governador term fornicator I was just
reading on the raft com one of my big
sources was basically forced to tell the
truth by the LA Times so you know how
does that paradigm independent films
well if it's a horror film your choices
are sort of in a great way being a
fundamentally kind of great market
driven way fangoria dread shot till you
drop you know there are more that I love
and I've trafficked with I just can't
think of at the same time some of those
might be owned by the same people you
know in a strange way the last 23 years
some of which I've sort of sat out by
planting a garden or lying on the beach
um the cut the consolidation of the
internet and the way that great quality
internet outlets and print
let's have sort of merged i'm thinking
the washington post's slate the New York
Times has created its own wonderful
video library it may seem like a
digression but New York one news Time
Warner Cable's all-news station in new
york city if you go on their website
there's a huge archive of content with
all prominent New Yorkers from all walks
of life it's called one-on-one with bud
Michigan all of those things have sort
of shifted the publicity paradigm in a
way that is it's sort of like a big reap
the way that Osama bin Laden's death is
a reboot for the culture on our energy
over the last few years everything has
become a lot easier at the same time the
market remains is glutted and horrible
as it ever has been for independent
Phelps they've become easier to make
they become less easy to market because
it's a tsunami does that even remotely
answer your question testing out a lot
more stuff there Jeremy yeah you had
something here in keeping with that so
then how has your job changed in the
last five years you know um in the
sector of independent film I five years
ago I was doing everything I could to
dominate say the press narratives that
would come out of the Sundance Film
Festival okay my staff and I would take
on a slate of films and I'm there are
other agencies that do this and I highly
recommend filmmakers going to sundance
look at these sort of i want to call
them full service agencies with the
staff because they're exactly right it's
great to take on a bunch of tums to
sundance if you have the staff and
experience and who understands the
sundance culture enough so that you can
service the film's service the
filmmakers properly there's nothing
wrong with that I just don't do that
anymore I would rather do what I did at
this year's sundance film festival
consult with an agent
see first on a specific plan do the
writing that kind of thing or I would
rather go to a film festival one or two
titles that I can really bring something
to so that's how I've changed in the
last five years how is publicity changed
in the last time here as well I think to
answer that question you had to sort of
ask how is the news business changed in
the last five years CNN has totally
changed the way it delivers news how
bout prioritizes things it's fascinating
to see them awkwardly go from wall to
wall coverage of Libya to all these
insane news stories lately and then
somehow try to fit in culture it's
interesting to see how that's going on
so publicity has to change with how the
news changes what is that sort of you
know part two of the newspaper okay what
what are the priorities for culture all
that changes with the priorities of the
day of the news of the day I truly
believe that and lastly let's go back to
the raft calm because I believe we wrote
an open letter to embody measurement
chairman Dodd and in it you talked about
a certain journalist who exposed key
elements of script I'm a script the
movie that I was working on that at the
time was still in production and you
know if any of you guys I don't know
enough about you but if you guys are any
of your viewers I've ever worked on a
movie set of any movie Hollywood spect
spectacle independent or interpersonal
drama you know how hard it was to get
there you know the spirit of
collaboration all the people that it
takes to make that movie and I do
believe that it is crime against cinema
to in the middle of production okay
because it's a in his age of giving
digital bits away here and there that is
how you market movies and there is a
fair play journalistic element I'm not
talking about that I'm talking about
with this journalist in her name is
bonnie Fuller she is her outlet is
called Bonnie Fuller's hollywood life
and it's hollywoodlife.com she revealed
twice and and and she knew full well
that by doing this she was bringing pain
she was stealing something that didn't
belong to her exploiting it for her own
use that sounds like thievery to me that
sounds like piracy to me that's what I
really I did become upset i was able to
tell us to one of the people who work in
our LA office on the phone i'll use this
platform now if you don't mind to
apologize to the LA office of
hollywoodlife.com because on that day i
was very upset and I did I use colorful
language I got upset i was being on the
phone to two people I'm sorry to these
those two people I apologize for my bad
behavior I was mean because I couldn't
get ahold of bonnie Fuller in New York I
made initial contact on that day in
April and they quite professionally and
cordially took down the thing right away
and then to put it back up a week later
knowing full well that it was a really
upsetting thing and I used the same
metaphor like kicking a pregnant woman
in the stomach on the phone as I did in
my letter to chairman Dodd um you know
so they they and the second time they
were ready for me they switched me to
their how closest they didn't want to
deal with me I wasn't you know I asked
to talk to bonny fuller I wasn't given
that opportunity so you know it is very
very upsetting to me and the reason I
sent that to Christopher Dodd
I just heard him talk about piracy and
to me it is as much a crime against
cinema for anyone to take something
that's not theirs hosts you know we work
in a business of narrative of fantasy to
take those salient moments from what may
be an old script what may have been cut
out from the movie may have been
reworked you know she's intruding on the
creative process and that's a crime and
I do believe that's a crime that's why I
made my letter to chairman Dodd and and
and I'm glad I want to thank the Raptor
posting because it's really important
stuff you know and I know that came up
earlier in the conversation here Jeremy
about sort of ethics you know you
mentioned on the ethics in that are sort
of in New York as a boat you know how
they may differ in Los Angeles I mean
how competitive is sort of the world of
publicity getting you know as as more
and more people are sort of just
reaching out and grabbing it and trying
to grant you know try it because it's
becoming harder to market and promote
because of the glut of content we see
you know how does that how does what
were thoughts run through your mind well
it's interesting you have perspective
that the market for publicity is more
competitive are you asking me about like
like uh you know you know more news
outlets more more more press outlets you
know and people maybe not honoring a
certain code of ethics that maybe you
should have grew up with in the business
I'm no angel I've made mistakes uh I one
slide to a reporter at The Hollywood
Reporter during the sundance film
festival this was 20 years ago I given
an exclusive news about Sony classics to
variety and the hot water heard about it
and I was tired and I didn't know what
to do and I learned my lesson you know
um I probably made bad decisions I've
probably been rude to people but
otherwise you know i think my reputation
is
relatively as a very affable and ethical
person and you know when ronni chasen
was murdered Anne Thompson and indieWIRE
to saw her death is the edge of civility
in Hollywood and I think that if I'm
known for one thing it's working in a
civil manner um and I think there was a
lot about the open letter to chris
renaud that wasn't necessarily civil i
did use colorful language but i think
you can act sternly and civilly in this
business at the same time so but at the
same time ethics are ethics I don't
think they've changed that much in the
last 10 20 years the other thing that
you're I think question has sort of as a
faulty premise if you will to borrow
something from Harvey Levin I found in
my sector of the industry that
independent film Sundance Tribeca
Toronto you know South by Southwest sort
of sector of the market publicists
aren't competitive their collegial we
all know each other we all come from the
same few places um you know so i will
say that there is in our segment of the
things and i'm not talking about every
public sister every halloween from
independent film we all know each other
we all like each other more or less i
refer business to competitive so called
competitors all the time people work for
business to me all the time we have
known each other for so long that we
know what is right for one not right
Fred we share business sometimes so you
know it's not as cutthroat as you make
it seem you guys
not forgive guy I read I read something
and maybe I'm just sort of putting my
own little spin on it so forgive me
they're just want to do elaborate you
have anything else I think covered a lot
here Thank You Jeremy sir I feel I've
been to my dentist I know if you and I
been talking for a long time about doing
this I really enjoyed our conversation I
hope it's helpful yes and but yeah and
thanks for the time yeah on our end
we're just we're fascinated by a Jeremy
and we're just so grateful that you
would take time out and we saw your cat
sort of floating in and out of the
background at time since I nice oh
really oh gosh oh my gosh all right
that'll make the video go viral
everybody gets their 15 minutes yeah
apparently oh well thank you for joining
us today song like this has been great
this is all right you guys take good
care okay thank you to thank you five